we're rolling we're rolling second Tina
Turner song you sang in 42nd ice-pan and
icon he was he was just singing I'm a
private dance music will do I have I
must tell you guys something about the
way we are shooting this we are still in
a pandemic and in California everyone
wears masks both of my male producers
are in masks and I feel like I'm in eyes
wide shut I'm kind of digging it this
whole thing is very erotic I just want
you guys to know if I get distracted
that's why I'm just getting randomly
aroused I also think that's sexual
harassment but else see you guys in
court grab a bit you ready
can you do a Tina Turner song and a bet
yeah I you know that because we've been
having some serious podcast the last
couple weeks because of what's been
going on in the world but comedians make
fun of our podcast with pop up out its
phantom Dylan and Kiev on they like
they'll be like bop bop bop so the war
in Syria pop up give all your money to
giraffes so your grandmother died in the
Holocaust tell us about that Bob Bob
juxtapose with how serious the podcast
event I realize we might need a more
serious one bop bop bop bean yeah we
might i I didn't expect for bop bop bop
to become a thing but people people
really enjoy it and I don't know why I'm
stupid it's so stupid if you guys want a
ringtone a pop up up it's on the website
it's on the front page
of the website you can't miss it I would
love nothing more than to be going
through the grocery store to just hear
someone go pop pop pop and it's there me
and just goes off one of your shows like
son of a bitch it's already like like I
feel like an annoying catchphrase that's
gonna haunt me okay so today's episode
is going to be a fun relationship advice
episode we had marami last week who was
amazing I mean truly amazing I know you
all have crushes on him now
it was I felt very deep and profound and
emotional and we talked about God and
all sorts of things so gently profound
for sure and we have not had time really
to get into y'all's questions I keep
posting about leaving messages on the
Google number and sending me messages
and I frankly just don't answer them and
I don't want to treat you all the way my
parents treated me I want to listen and
I want to answer your questions because
yet people will text me on will just bug
are you gonna answer that question you
know so that's what we're gonna do today
we're gonna answer relationship
questions voicemails all of it we sure
are but don't you have some
announcements first I sense some anger
in your voice and resentment because you
know you do the announcements and you're
putting me on the spot so you want to
get off track you're putting me on the
spot and I don't appreciate it well
there's some announcement whatever hey
you cancelled San Diego San Diego is
canceled the show is canceled
bummer real bummer Zeroni came through
yeah as much as I wanted to shut it down
as much as I wanted to shoot a show
called comedians and comedy clubs
getting Kovan I decided we had to cancel
that one wiseguys in in Salt Lake City
we hope that ones on we hope Alabama's
on but it's out of our control believe
it or not uh-huh
what's the next one - one is Miami
Oklahoma in I don't know I here's the
thing this is why I do this community
texting thing it's called where you guys
text me eight one eight two three nine
seven five two seven that's it to
dyslexic people trying to say phone
number on a podcast
I directly will text people in whatever
city they're in specifically so when I
was trying to figure out what to do
about San Diego I would only text people
from San Diego that had texted me it was
like a couple thousand of you asking
like how is it there what's it like are
you guys wearing masks what's the vibe
do you want to go out to a comedy show
so that's why if you want to know what's
going on with touring just text me at
this number I've said it before I don't
want your data I wouldn't even know what
to do with it we don't sell your data
this was just so much easier than that's
going door-to-door to try to get you to
come to my show and convert you to a
Jehovah's Witness some of you live and
walk up it was just too much is a lot
and so this is a way that I can connect
with you directly so Salt Lake City
Huntsville Miami Oklahoma and then
Atlanta Boston
Mansa huckett Connecticut Nashville
Tennessee text me and I can give you
guys updates cuz everyone's like what's
going on with the show and then I put it
in the main feed and it doesn't get in
the algorithm and no one likes the photo
cuz my tits aren't in it
so I need you to text me it's also
always on the website also really
recently took control of my brand he's
had it with me posting comedy videos and
he is now like a stage mom who forces me
to wear bikinis outside in my pool and
post them on Instagram about to break
downs away from pasties it's really I
you Benton makes me wear bathing suits
and pose for Instagram and then he's
like this got half a million likes I'm
like yeah no shit my tits are up to my
chin would you ban for to prove my dad
wrong man you are your dad never thought
you'd give views like that engagement
like that okay I'm all ready so you guys
you know that I'm obsessed with these
blue light glasses
what cuz I look at computers all day now
for work and I've been wearing these
blue light glasses but because my face
is so goddamn greasy and shiny they are
covered in what looks like clam chowder
and all I end up doing is cleaning them
all day do they look dirty no I don't
have my glasses on so I can't you can't
really see each other okay so those are
I think all the boring ass announcement
we have now why don't we get into the
relationship questions that you guys
sent that I have not gotten to thank you
for your patience Benton you ready I'm
ready
all right why are you I feel like you're
you're awfully um patient with me today
that was me being excited are you ready
yeah weird to see with brown hair Benton
has come to my house every day this week
with a different hair color are you
running from the law I'm a living
rainbow yes true but so today you just
chose regular brown yeah today I'm going
back to my roots okay
look at it love a punt okay
unfortunately yes and you're fired thank
you so here we go okay first question is
it acceptable to try and change things
about your partner such as fashion
friends and spending habits oh it's a
great question before I give my answer I
do want to admit that when I was in my
20s I did try to change every person I
dated the person I dated their identity
was just a gentle suggestion of what
they were to become like when I was in
my 20s I would date someone and I would
be like I love you now let's get to work
roll up my sleeves I'm gonna flip this
house like I should have had it like a
dating show on HGTV Lily what it is
after a week you got all your friends go
you were like move back you know for me
like I think that I never I didn't know
who I was you know so I just wanted to
focus on changing the other person I
would look at boyfriends like projects
you know and it probably makes sense of
my favorite toy growing up was mr.
Potato Head so I think I brought that
into my life later where I'm like oh
we're gonna take that mustache off and
put on a pair of glasses and you're
gonna have this hat on like I thought
that was my job as a woman was to change
everything about the person you were
dating it was like that's what love was
right to make you the best version of
yourself which is uh so dumb because why
are you just turning the person you're
in
with into more of a catch someone else
all your boyfriend's a builder barity my
American Girl doll and you know so now I
see it totally differently because you
know I I don't want to make the person
I'm with into a someone better for the
next person that comes along so now when
I'm dating someone I'm like no I love
those jeans with the orange stitches
wear those every day yes those Crocs
look perfect with those socks and why
not just wear a fanny pack if your
wallet doesn't fit in your pocket I have
a perfect tie-dye fanny pack that goes
right so they've given up shark taking
people or you were just like I know you
love flip-flops but what about a Chelsea
boot for nothing but I also I'm thinking
about it if I couldn't change the other
person I would change myself like III
think that is this weird instinct we
have as humans when you meet someone
that you have to become fraternal twins
I don't know what it's a way to like
think you have more in common than you
actually do it like you don't have to
dress alike and look alike like you know
I mean in my 20s I went from like goth
girl to preppy girl like to whoever I
was dating I would try to shape-shift to
be their dream girl or what I thought
they thought their dream girl was you
were bar being kidding it I really was
and if I couldn't change them I would
shape-shift you know myself like all of
a sudden I would be into like fishing
and snowboarding you know like like
whatever I think is gonna make you stay
I was like a shitty spy in my 20s every
time you saw me I was like a completely
different person and I think that we do
it for like a false sense of intimacy
because it does take a long time to get
to know someone but I think it's how we
convince ourselves that we have more in
common that we actually do but I
actually think you shouldn't have
everything in common with the other why
would you want to date someone who was
exactly like you that's so nurses
they've gotten to the point where you're
like is that a woven belt in my house
you know but I also um I'm thinking
about it cuz for a while I was dating
older guys I dated older guys for a
while and you can't change them they're
too set in their ways
you can't and I and I'm I'm done dating
older guys not only because that just
because I realized you can't get older
guys to listen to good music like that
that's something that's the thing that I
do tend to want to change is someone's
taste in music because that's the one
thing you actually have to really
experience with the other person all the
time everybody thinks they have the best
taste in music everyone's gone through
life I have the best days of course but
I'm saying like that's a deal breaker
for me because it's on all the time and
like older guys music is always so
creepy when you think about it like it's
always like she's got legs and she knows
how to use them you're like woof to walk
like I wouldn't you really think about
that song you're like oh God
like you're going on a road trip with an
older guys and it's like girls girls
girls Jesus music is wild women have to
go write songs about their leg these
boots are made for walking my legs this
is a cycle of terrible this older guy
and we were like on some road trip up
like the California cars or something
and it were just like hey little girl is
your daddy home is it going to leave you
all alone
whoo I got a bad dessert Jesus that is
the bird spring singsong we're just like
I don't know I'm on fire you're like oh
God you know let's turn the clock hey is
your daddy who the nickname hello darlin
but I do I mean look yes we have an
instinct to change the people we get I
made a move I literally made a movie
about you know in the female brain there
was a whole storyline with James Marsden
and Lucy punch but there's a difference
between trying to change something about
someone and grooming grooming we
actually do get you know oxytocin
dopamine and serotonin from popping the
person you're with zits and plucking
their eyebrows like that's a grooming
instinct you know that's what the whole
story was about a career you just choose
it's also yes you can also just become a
manicure
you can you know that that's love like
that's a grooming instinct you know the
guy that I'm dating this morning I was
like cutting his cuticles at the Friday
this morning I'm dating this morning I
was like driving me nuts that he had
these like cuticles hanging out so I
started cutting his cuticles but I do
think if you're gonna change them but
just know that it does come with a price
like I think when we try to change
people like get them to dress a certain
way get them did you have a certain
haircut we think that we're like solving
some big problems they have we think
that that's like love but it's gonna
corrode the relationship we think
they're so grateful for it's adult
bullying it's absolutely bullying and
the other person has just decided it's
easier to let you do this you know like
this is obviously this is something you
need so badly but just know that it's
got a corrode a relationship like if you
say to your man I want you to shave your
beard and I want you to stop wearing
those cargo shorts and I you can't hang
out with these friends like and you just
Marie Kondo their entire life it's gone
there it's gonna come back yeah it'll be
better but they will hate you well yeah
whether it's in in two months or two
years it's gonna be like I gave up my
favorite cargo shorts for you you know
it's it's never I think without you know
some kind of future consequence like
you're you are breeding some kind of
resentment in the future you know
there's you if there's there's nothing
men love more it's keeping score they
love gay football's not on right now
basketballs not on right now they have
to figure out some new sport and it's
probably keeping score in their
relationship so I would just say let him
keep that dartboard
let him keep all the hoodies you know
like it's I just because I think a lot
of people don't understand like you just
said it whatever people are doing is to
manage some insecurities they have so
when you're saying shave that beard you
might be saying don't be insecure about
your chin yeah you know like for
pointing at me trying to think of an
example of like most I think we a suit
we just roast people and bully people
under the guise of helping sometimes you
know yeah and I think that a lot of
people don't necessarily understand that
whatever they wear or whatever
you know like she wears turtlenecks all
the time maybe she's insecure about her
neck I don't know yeah like he's always
in a hoodie his boobs yeah exactly like
there could be some reason that the
person has chose that fashion choice
that you don't know about and you're
basically asking them to have a
different childhood or by saying take
that Metallica poster now and you might
be saying I want you to have ten years
of therapy that you've not had yet yeah
you know the guy that I used to date a
guy who was very into Slayer and
Metallica and what's the other really no
he was cool it's what you're trying to
say it was awesome is it no but I mean
it was like he would like listen to it
really loudly and it was some kind of
anger thing or some kind of emotion
we're not your mom's basement anymore
well he was like working through some
emotional thing and I'm like you have to
play that so loud and then when he
stopped play it so loud his anger would
come out in different ways and I was
like oh yeah you need that Metallica you
need to go on that run or do your
pull-ups too Slayer whatever the
punching bag yeah that thing that I had
a note on it was a solution to an
emotional problem like I didn't realize
the whack Amole that I was disturbing
yeah it turns out you didn't want to
talk through that did you yeah no never
like got it look I got your record
player yeah no just play go back to
whatever that was and I also you have to
just put yourself in the other person
she's like I don't like it when someone
tries to change me you know it's because
my thing with that is like no one has
more notes on me than me like don't I
don't need someone else to not like me
I'm already doing that like I changed
myself tomorrow yeah I'm good and I
think because I think what we do is we
assume that people aren't insecure when
we do that and we assume that our help
is perceived the way we're trying to
give it you know really go I'm just
helping you by buying you this entire
new wardrobe it's like no you're just
hurting my feelings we think that we had
the best idea and we're just gifting it
to you here's what I'll say though it is
kind of hot when a guy tells you to wear
a certain thing what's a man just got
really quiet in here as I took my drink
of coffee
I there there's a difference between
like I've dated guys who I know don't
like the way I dress cuz I guess they're
not in minimum I guess they're not into
Santa Fe lesbians and that's their
problem
but what a guy is like we're going to
I put on that blue dress like that's
kind of hot yeah when he leans in like
like that is hot but don't expect me to
do that all the time do you don't mean
because I've had guys complain that I
dressed you sloppy like I'm over there
like do you always have to wear pajamas
like when we go to dinner I'm like yes I
do this is me being authentic I want to
be comfortable carrying this wallet
around and like there's you can do that
every now and then and it's hot you know
so I think it's just like the way you're
doing like guys doing it is tricky like
I know women sometimes guys need a woman
to a woman's touch sometimes you need
that ingrown hair plucked off your badge
parlors sometimes there's a giant hair
in a mole that needs to be removed by a
woman that's not trying to change
somebody that's like nothing you're not
like converting them to Scientology or
something like I think I think it's just
like finding that balance one thing I
just really don't like is when guys what
they try to change about a woman is
telling them not to wear makeup today I
have been fighting about this for days
so let me just write this is the thing
that really is a no-no when guys say to
a woman I wish you wouldn't wear so much
makeup let me just just give me a second
to collect my thoughts because rage is
starting to bubble up and I'm starting
to sweat
first of all guy and I'm not talking
about me like I my makeup right now I
look like a bull of time I mean I don't
ever tell me to change my face looks
like a bowl of Lucky Charms and that is
a choice I have made in quarantine to
try to cheer myself up because I'm blue
and so is my eyeliner
that's just how I've evolved but when
guys tell women I don't think you guys
understand when you tell women not to
wear makeup you don't know what you're
saying because you don't know what
makeup is what you're saying is I want
it to look like the way Jennifer Lopez
is look you mean if you want a natural
look done by professionals warm with a
smoky eye I'm saying when guys say I
love it when you don't wear makeup you
don't know what you're saying what
you're actually trying to say is I want
you to have airbrushed expertly blended
natural make I want you look tan wet
that's right they want Browns and beiges
and golds what they're saying is I don't
want me to look like a two-bit floozy
like a clown that just came out of the
rain they want it done well the you know
but I also think they think it's a
compliment I think they really believe
telling that is yeah being like you're
so beautiful you don't need it but
here's a fun fact it's not for you it's
not for you and you don't know when I'm
wearing it
so there's times that I will have just
foundation on and I'll come downstairs
and the guy I'm dating is like oh you
look so much prettier without makeup and
I'm like no I'm wearing makeup mm-hmm me
without makeup doesn't look neutral it
looks red my face is red and blue every
without makeup I you can see veins in my
skin every girl's been told you look
really tired oh okay are you sick
that's what if I don't wear makeup you
just go do you have kovat yeah can you
taste this taste this can you smell this
can you smell like that I don't think
guys understand I think when guys say
they don't want you to wear makeup
number one they're saying get that shit
off your lips because I don't want to
kiss it yeah and you're saying well I
have to wear makeup because of your
stubble
I have small wounds all over my I have
to cover up all the rug burn on my chin
from your fucking stubble yes that's
part of the reason we have to wear
makeup but no I do think that what guys
are actually saying guys don't like
goopy lip gloss like that mac lipglass
remember when that came out it's like
made of like what is that like stucco
it's it's made it's rubber cement it's
made out of it so I think there was a
time I remember when I used to wear that
a guys would be like can you not work so
much makeup you're so much prettier that
make up it's just like please get that
caulk off my face that's for looking not
touching yeah exam over right and so I
and I think that guys do that because
they don't want us to get our shit on
their shirts and pillowcases right and
guys understand makeup so little that
when that happens they're like shit a
fuse like is grease we were did we what
did a bird should I know if I like hug a
guy at a wedding and he's in like a
white shirt and you know what like the
second you see that you've rubbed your
makeup on somebody's shoulder you're
like oh fuck
and the guys like what's this is this
app for me
that diamond was like her skin her face
on Priscilla I think I definitely had
guys complain about like self-tanner
coming off and on their sheets it just
looks like skid marks it just looks like
you had explosive diarrhea and they're
bad like I get why that's a little
annoying so I think if guys ask you did
not do that I'm but when guys say I love
it when you know we're makeup you're so
much prettier that makeup like I just I
call bullshit on that it's such a
confusing thing to tell a girl because
like there's no porn category that's
like fresh-faced beauties right girls
with no makeup you're like show me all
the women you like and we'll talk about
whose do they have yeah okay why does
jenna jameson have a hundred billion
dollars if you hate girls wearing too
much makeup like I think they think what
guys mean when they say that is they
don't want eyelashes like coming off
they don't want to look like black widow
spiders or falling on their you know
better love the Amish if that's what you
think and yeah I just I just I died I
think that sometimes even when we are
trying to convey something that's a
preference for us we don't even always
necessarily know what we're asking for
you know but the spending someone asked
can you change them in spending habits
that is a no I would say no because
spending is so emotional you know it's a
very emotional thing and because I've
definitely had a lot of guys be like
well why don't you just spend less money
on makeup I don't know the same reason
that you spend I have all this makeup
the same reason you spend four hours a
day playing fantasy football whatever
why does your 2002 Toyota Corolla have
rims exactly did you just call my face a
2002 Toyota Corolla team that always
loses 120 bucks yeah it's not rational
cuz I've definitely been in a lot of
situations for guys so people won't you
just not spend all this money on makeup
or Y which is what I actually was
thinking last night because I remember
you telling me that when you were a
makeup artist at Sephora guys would say
don't put a lot of makeup on her yeah
they'd be the least damage but hold on
explain that to me when you did makeup
it's a four of men would come yeah they
would come with her majority of the time
they would come with their wife
specially there was something important
like a date at dinner a wedding they
would
and the girls would be like like as like
they'd be like using like a lot of
makeup so we have to do this and then if
you were in you be like okay well you
shouldn't wear a lot of makeup then and
as you were doing it they would like
stand behind you and be like well that's
too much eye shadow or she doesn't like
that all right or you know oh shit my
blush like that or they would give you
examples of other women like well you
know scar Johansson show his words like
this and you're like she's Photoshop
maybe just stand there and tell you what
to do and then Okanogan and the girls
would be like yeah yeah he doesn't like
that he doesn't like a lot of that which
I would always be like well then you
shouldn't marry him
well I don't know maybe he doesn't have
to buy it but yeah I would not tell
women not to buy makeup or that didn't I
thought about they would tell women not
to buy back then Body Works lotion ok
Benton and I have been fighting about
this for literally three days now and I
think it's gonna ruin our entire
friendship so I've had a guy say before
because my bathroom looks like a flea
market it looks I like to feel like I'm
in a CBS at all times I there's so few
things we can control in our lives
I like to just walk in and just I like
to feel like I'm doing like a
supermarket sweep
even that I like to have a different
lotion in every day I like to mix it up
I like to mix them together like I never
smell the same two days in a row I'm
mixing the rose I'm mixing the
honeysuckle you never know what I'm
gonna smell like that's my little weird
ritual in the morning and so I've had
guys be like why do you need ten lotions
because Bath & Body Works is a Ponzi
scheme okay better sedan by Benton
I bet it's okay look we're gonna do a
role play of me wanting to buy lotions
from Bath and Body Works Benton and I
are walking in the mall and we're a
couple yeah work up own plot twist okay
we're a couple that's me walking loved
it hey babe honey honey
what I think I've been I call you babe
babe what I want to stop it by the body
works real quick they're having a sale
yeah they have a sell every time we walk
by we're just here two weeks ago
remember you about eight lotion for $8
yeah
what is steel you still have them I know
and I'm gonna use them mmm you said that
three weeks ago we also buddy lotion
but you under but eight look this is now
a sale $12 eight lotions how can we not
do that right but remember you wanted to
go to the beach so do you want to go to
the beach or smell like the beach okay I
want moonlit Beach smell okay but we
could save that money and go to the
beach I know by the moon but you're
getting eight lotions for $12 that's a
deal it's August and you still smell
like gingerbread we're not going through
them that fast are we I want to smell
like candy canes in August it's a
surprising nostalgic perk perky
uplifting smells like I found you
between the seats in my car it's weird
candy cane shouldn't be that hot it's
August stop it okay do you want to buy
soaps I'll let you buy soap so here we
are
oh you let me cash in on this amazing
deal because you cannot physically go
through that many lotions before they
expire so I I never know what lotion I'm
gonna want to wear I some days I want to
smell a tropical silk other days I want
to smell like a Brazil nut no poor what
if I want to smell like an enchanted
meadow tomorrow listen you know that bag
you've been wanting pee we could have
already bought it by now purse the purse
it's a bad a bag you really are being a
straight guy yeah I've already bought it
by now but you spend half of our life
savings on cashmere sent to can't even
have a sentence but don't want you're
the one that gets to enjoy my body I
just want you to be naked like socks
you're really able to lock into this
straight guy fuck socks for a long time
throwing up so do you want to keep in
this conversation we're gonna miss our
movie we're gonna miss John wick - okay
time out Benton's back to being Benton
what is your problem with lotions being
on sale it's you cannot go through that
many lotions that fast so your point is
it's not a steal because you're not
actually using my thing is if ins are or
if that is the price to buy that many
lotions items then you could have just
saved and got you a good night
quality lotion I've been happier in the
long run okay your point is you don't
spend eight dollars on eight lotions
spent or twice spent $20 on one good
lotion yeah but this is this is really
the crux of what Benton has come into my
life to teach me lotions expire guess
things expire I didn't know that about
on the bottle what else that what name
the cosmetics that expire and then we'll
know everything later
anything that's not a powder expired
cream will expire liquids creams
mascaras bacteria if it is not a powder
it will expire decided what if I want to
smell like enchanted mold no I will say
that if you go to buy somebody works and
you want to spend that money on candles
soaps any of that stuff that's fine body
washes lotions stupid hitting the hard
topics here I'm good for you
okay you next week all right we're
taking a little break here to talk about
daily harvest that was beautiful I'm
really impressed let's talk about daily
harvest we've talked about it before you
guys have seen me on Instagram eating
daily harvest and right now if you're
watching on YouTube you can watch me
open up the daily harvest Benton now God
how you use the daily all right now
that's so good this way but it is
delicious okay so people hate when I eat
on the podcast I don't blame them I'm
obsessed with these daily harvests
because I have no qualms about the fact
that I cannot cook I don't want to cook
it's not a skill that I'm interested in
acquiring I feel no shame about it I am
a workaholic and I like to have my time
and these little daily harvests that
you're gonna read about in a second cuz
you know I don't read the copy because
I'm not a shill I do this because I
believe in the product they give you
these pre-made smoothies and soups and
all you have to do is like blend them up
or like put hot water in it and it's all
done and healthy
there's the breezy it's like super super
fancy like ramen noodles yeah they're
delicious and they're good and they're
healthy
this one is oat mulberry and dragon
fruit and if you can see I'm trying to
hold it up without spilling all over my
computer it comes with all the oats and
everything in it
then you just blend it up I'm right now
eating it with my hands because I'm a
pig
you just made a granola but you can
basically if you want this is I blend
this up in a blender but you could put
hot water in here and it makes like
instant oatmeal with mulberries and
blueberries and it's just like
healthiest crap yeah right now in daily
harvest is helping beat the heat with
refreshing smoothies and delicious
scoops their new plant-based ice cream
scoops are free of additives
preservatives and fillers because
they're made whole nourishing organic
ingredients like black sesame coconut
cream and dragon fruit and they have
amazing flavors daily harbor can you not
swallow so hard cheese me can woo you're
all but eating the microphone these are
really good
Daniel harvest is a lifesaver they help
you stuff your home with clean delicious
foods that's built on real fruits and
vegetables they're from their frozen to
locking you chew and it's making me
laugh their farm frozen to lock in peak
nutrients and taste I don't have
children but if I did this is all that
we do is just give them these because
they're healthy you're on to think about
it you don't wear it and by the way no
mess you just put hot water in here and
it's done it's handled I mean this is
most feminist shit I've ever seen Ares
these daily harvests and you just put
them all in the freezer
I've got soups umm ball there was one
that was like a commodities yeah oh yeah
there's one that's like a coffee blend
but you know blended drink yeah and it's
all natural ingredients cuz I feel like
um I just eat so many cups so much trash
chemicals but eating clean fun with
daily harvest is easy and effortless
whether you're having a night at home or
need a quick bite on-the-go everything
stays fresh and your freezer until
you're ready to enjoy it and look at
this there's no red number five or my co
buns alanda late organic whole wheat
grains raspberries blueberries organic
dragon fruit organic mulberries that's
it all ready for you right here
keep it simple this summer with daily
harvest you know is it daily harvest
calm and enter promo code good for you
to get $25 off your first box that's
good for you for $25 off your first box
at daily harvest calm
that's daily harvest dot-com beautiful
these dragon fruits are that is a
raspberry that's a dragon poop if
opinions aren't your thing
you might want to go to better if
opinions from comedians aren't solving
all your life problems you might want to
also run this by a therapist at better
help.com I'm sure they're gonna agree
with our advice yeah play this podcast
for them is there something interfering
with your happiness usually preventing
you from achieving your goals both yeah
better help will access your needs and
match you with your own licensed
professional therapist look I'm gonna
level with you it's a hard time
everyone's going a little bit nuts we're
stressed out we're full of fear we're
scared were anxious more angry I walk
down the street the my mask is literally
a millimeter under my nose people like
watch your mask I mean there's a lot of
emotion and they weren't wrong yeah I
think and then I got insecure and I'm
everyone's at peak stress right now and
I think that especially because we can't
do a lot of things in person better help
is the most genius thing you can do for
yourself right now it's not a crisis
line it's not self-help it's
professional counseling done securely
online we talk a lot about mental health
on this podcast also everyone wants to
take care of their immune system some of
the best way you can take care of your
immune system is to de-stress and to
take care of your mental wealth because
stress weakens your immune system so
this is available for clients worldwide
you can log into your account anytime
send a message to your counselor timely
and thoughtful responses you can
schedule weekly video or phone sessions
with a professional therapist I mean
that's in me that's amazing it's truly
amazing you can do it wherever you got I
wish this was available when I was in my
20s and you don't have to go sit in a
waiting room you don't have to go
through any of that stress right now
it's your help on your time pretty much
and it's more affordable than
traditional offline counseling financial
aid is available put your mental health
first everything else will fall into
place better help calm / Whitney that's
better h e LP enjoying the over 1
million people taking charge of their
mental health with the help of an
experienced professional so many people
have been using better help that they're
actually recruiting additional
counselors in all 50 states that is
awesome special offer for good for you
listeners get 10% off your first month
at better help calm / Whitney and this
is not written in the ad but if you guys
want to text me or DM me how your
experience is and what you're going
through I always always want to read
them I did want to write down a couple
things that I think are fair game to
change in someone still answering the
same question this is why we don't get
questions because it takes me an hour to
answer one question if you what these
are the things I believe you should be
able to change in a person we'd have a
question about lotion still oh Jesus
Christ we talked about this three days
you buy extra lotions because you're
worried that you're at your boyfriend
will still one of them well yeah because
the guys always going to take one to
jerk off with yeah I have a trick for
that you wanna Jergens tanning lotion
and then you know they have a sunset
colored dick and then you're gonna know
exactly who stole your lotion that's
such a good way to find out if a guy is
stealing your lotion put dirt
self-tanner yeah and the one that you
suspect he's taking there you go why
does your dick smell like an enchanted
meadow have you been jerking off with my
Bath & Body Works that's why you do it
like a big cheeto what's the cheeto
puffs in your pants oh god that is so
funny
oh okay something that you are allowed
these are the things that I change these
are the only things I will change in a
person cuz I'm now at a point where I
accept people who they are
unconditionally and don't try to change
them because I'm in a program and I have
to these are called boundaries and what
is love stand for was just an al-anon
meeting this morning what's the acronym
for love stand for love is ladies others
voluntarily evolved
mm-hmm that was vicious erection that's
your version of love so you're allowed
to set boundaries like I recently got in
a fight with my lover because I own him
that don't call him that
yeah I don't like I've not I don't home
quarantine lover anymore just calm lover
kovat lover got we got in a fight about
that the time limit on that one I don't
let ya only 14 days no symptoms I don't
like when guys call women chicks yes she
prefers chicken cage a pigeon gal bird
bitch anything but that chicken head
it's fine
like will being cut my finger words like
I get like weirded out by certain words
like wife beater like I can you not say
that just I like lady puncher I know
that's what it's called but like that I
get hung up not on like the person's
wardrobe or their hairstyle or anything
like that like words bother me like like
he'll come home and I'll just be like
anyway so this chick at work today and
I'm like like I just get your coworker
like why are you calling her you mean
the woman you work gonna be a farmer
yeah like he's totally like it just like
the woman you work with and I also don't
like young lady so it's talking to this
young lady like what why are you
bringing her age into it like I did the
math yeah why are you doing the math on
her age just say woman just call
everyone a woman I want to know if she's
valuable I wonder if she's so this
fertile girl yeah that I work with like
it's just like I've egg factory I don't
know I can't explain it but it's just
weird and it's the kind of thing where
if you say something you do sound like a
crazy feminazi or whatever but it's just
it distracts me and so I will ask for
things like that I'll go hey I know that
this probably sounds dramatic but when
you call a woman chick like it makes me
feel weird could you just call women
women thank god I'll call them female as
you're right don't go oh I'm a scientist
females so this female I saw earlier at
the grocery store like wild you believe
my phone and I saw a female in the wild
so yeah those are those are personal
preferences and I'll say like it's my
personal preference you can talk to your
guy friends however you want I just
don't like locker room talk
so that's not me saying change who you
are it's just when you're around me
could you completely pretend you're a
different person but that to me is more
of a boundary like I also the one other
thing I will change about a man is hot
take I want you to grow your chest hair
not shave your chest sir yeah no I don't
I don't what I when I meet a guy in his
chef's participation I'm really getting
flustered just thinking about it if your
chest is shaved that's are you trying to
run away how aerodynamic you need to be
what are you why are you so short you're
trying to swim away trying to get
through my moat quickly there's slip and
slide out back I don't know about like
cuz then also you have stubble on your
chest which I'm not a huge fan of like
fucking a cactus yes rub me because a
cheese grater you're like are you derma
rolling my whole body I love derma
rolling but not my not my boobs I paid a
lot of money for this I'm gonna pop one
here's double that delicate I wrote down
another one oh sleeping with the TV on
absolutely incorrigible
reprehensible deal-breaker how are you
gonna live in a nursing home I plan to
die before that because me yes so that's
another thing that's not like I'm trying
to change you it's just that I cannot
sleep in the same room with someone
who's a psychopath who sleeps with the
television on it's very normal it's not
normal been tonight by the way argued
about this for about an hour yesterday
you don't know about us we argue all we
do all we do we are the Lucy and Desi of
the quarantine and I'm not sure you
don't know Lucy and Desi oh you really
don't I don't you don't know who Lucy
and Desi I wouldn't lie do you guys know
who Lucy and Desi are you don't know who
Lucille Ball is oh yes I do I never lose
her husband his name desi yes okay
yes I remember the bed is a baby it's
very confusing because you're the most
adult you want how about Ross and Rachel
you want to talk about Romney Michelle
you want to talk about Trisha Paytas
yeah I only watch movie Lisa Kudrow's it
so Benton knows everything about like
youtubers and tick stalkers and like
three of the friends I know most
celebrities you know the name of the man
on friends yeah Ross Chandler Joey whoa
okay I can name another last names too
really Geller Monica Geller yeah
Chandler Bing Rachel Greene yes Rachel
grant and then Joey he's always the
heart Fatone no Tribbiani it's Tribbiani
I knew it Oh God we do a game show we
need to do a game show with you and
Taylor Tomlinson because she didn't know
anything about 1990s music when I had
her on here are the other things I would
change about someone again they're not
changing these are just your own
personal boundaries a personal boundary
I set that isn't change who you are it's
just don't drip water on my fucking
floor if I see any droplets of water on
my floor Cova droplets are even fine as
long as I can't see them but you know my
biggest third rail is when there's water
on my wooden floor yes it is it really
drives me to war ooh
sitting on the couch in a wet bathing
suit
you fucking mongrel I mean that's crazy
I've definitely dated guys we'll just
get out of the pool and they're just
gonna sit on the couch and you're just
like in what world truly never I think
people get in cars and that triggers me
with what bathing suits on that's so
insane Buffay Phoebe Buffay this last
one Phoebe Buffay that's right what was
her sister's name her twin sister okay
stop
Ursula it is nurse yeah okay moving on
she was a character on Mad About You we
love this dump in the couch and wet
bathing suit
okay I mean
by the way I spend enough time on that
question only 40 minutes Jesus Christ
wait this one's pretty quick huh what's
the best relationship advice you ever
received don't sit on my couch and a
fuckin bathing suit that's great don't
come to my house best relationship
advice I've ever received
actually we've talked about a couple of
these things on the podcast I love don't
go to the problem for the solution do
you love them like I got in a fight with
my lover yesterday and instead of
texting my lover going I don't like this
behavior doing I text a girlfriend I go
hey this behavior he's doing is annoying
and they'll go oh mine does that to him
you just call him in cameo cameo to him
we don't do cameo fuck cameo did I love
burning a random bridge with cameo so
that's a good one
don't the person that caused the problem
is probably not the person that's gonna
solve the problem you don't go the
problem for the solution you go get the
solution and bring the solution to your
relationship the solution might be don't
bring it up at all that's a freaking
hardest shit one but sometimes it is
like I had an issue with my lover the
other night he doesn't even know about
it cuz guess what it's my problem his
guests point i bottled enough burst just
what it's because of an invisible wound
my dad left and it's not his job to
solve my problem it's mine god I'm at or
oh here's another one I love don't get
everything from one person you cannot
get everything from one person Amazon
your boyfriend's not your phone you
can't get everything emotionally from
them I just like that because I think
that for the longest time I would get in
a relationship and I thought that my
boyfriend was like my best friend and my
therapist and my girlfriend and my you
know mini golf buddy and my like you
know that was random but I love mini
golf yeah like it's a known fact you're
not you're not gonna get everything from
one person like I would be full like Tom
Hanks in castaway with the fucking beach
ball when I would get in a relationship
I wouldn't talk to any of my girlfriends
I would just completely sort of
disappear into a relationship and then
wonder why it wasn't working cuz I was
trying to get all my emotional needs met
from one
oh this is the other one I wanted to do
so I read this in a book Elizabeth
Gilbert
she wrote that book Eat Pray Love that I
didn't I was not as into it as everybody
was I know it's a big phenom in the litt
world and Julie Roberts was in the movie
member the author that wrote that also
wrote a book called committed I
recommend it to anyone that's trying to
figure out what the fuck the point of
anything is in relationships and she
went all around the world to different
cultures to explore what marriage meant
in every culture mm-hmm and she talks
about something called closing the doors
and windows oh yeah in a relationship
which which just means when you're in a
relationship you have to make sure to
emotionally invest with that person
about the important things in your life
for example if you're at work and you
get a big promotion or you get in a big
fight with someone at work don't first
tell another co-worker about it call
your partner and tell them so that they
are participating in the emotional sort
of ups and downs of your life so that
you stay intimate so that you don't do
what thing what I've done what mommy did
auntie Whitney did in her 20s which is
like share with your co-workers all the
drama that's going on in your life and
then two months later you're at home
with your boyfriend and you're like well
you don't understand me Craig
understands me it's like well that's
because you only tell Craig at work
what's going on with you who's who's
Craig first of all you know so you have
to make sure you save some of your
because you really only have to
emotionally invest and confide in
someone like once a day so you have to
make sure you save some of that for your
partner to maintain that intimacy so you
don't grow apart yeah because the doors
and windows cuz when you first tell me
that I was like close the doors and
windows and then what leave the car
running it's like carbon monoxide
poisoning like kill em out was looking
close the doors and windows lock them so
they can't leave that is my advice to
trap them in your home or steps to
having a hostage and doors and windows
handcuff them to the best put them in
the basement no it's I don't know why
it's called that but it's a great I
should put somewhere on the in the
podcast notes the page it's on because
it's a it just made me realize there
were times I would be in relationships
but also working really busy jobs and
then be like oh the person I'm with
doesn't
understand what I go through doesn't
understand my life only my coworker
understands me maybe this person's my
soulmate nearly no I've just told this
person everything and not and I've kept
my boyfriend out of the loop so of
course they can't console me or
understand what I'm going through
because I haven't looped them in right
which makes perfect sense yeah but it's
got its a it's a I don't know if I've
explained or to think about it in the
moment though because you just want to
talk about the feeling that you're
having right then with her yes yes you
have to just like text your boyfriend or
text your girlfriend or get on the phone
with them and tell them what's going on
and make sure that they're looped into
what's wrong you have to have but it's
also sometimes by the time you get home
you don't need to talk about it coz you
ready talked about it with someone else
yeah and you don't want to rehash it but
then the person's like well what went on
tell me and you're like oh I like this
thing and you're just and then they're
like are you okay are you mad are you
there look I don't need to talk about it
again I already did and then they just
become like a nuisance to you I also the
best piece of advice I think I ever got
and this is gonna be polarizing you know
me and my hot takes my takes just get
hotter and hotter every week lovin I
just pulled some my hair out am i
shedding I was one time at the Comedy
Store this was god I was probably 26 and
in the beginning when I started stand-up
I could not get good spots like in the
beginning you get the two a.m. spots you
know and back this was back in the
comedy store before Joe Rogan had come
back there weren't a lot of people there
there was always like five Germans in
the audience like it was just like a
very weird eerie place without big
crowds and I would go on at like 2:00 in
the morning and I remember I had just
gotten cheated on like I I got back to
my kind of got back together with a guy
that we had been fighting but didn't
really break up and I grabbed his jacket
to run down to the comedy store to do my
spot and I reached in the pockets and
they had condoms in them and went back
and screamed at him and he had any
flavor for you yeah they were in classic
hearing room they were evocative kind
they were the ones that are the glasses
clinic did you they were yellow neon
yellow and and so I went back and
confronted him and he told me he was
sleeping with somebody else and so I was
just like a wreck and then I ran on
stage and completely abandoned my
material because I couldn't focus and I
this is literally a bunch of PEEP
all that we have now unstuck he's
hysterically crying on stage and an
oversight oversized jacket full of
condoms like similar to now I don't so i
there were so few people in the audience
that i literally didn't even do stand-up
i was like you guys should i called what
should i do like i just was asking them
for help i was a real catch back then
and i had my phone out cuz he kept
texting me and calling me and i was like
you guys what should i do and everyone's
like ah maybe you should just let him
know that he shouldn't share your house
like people were trying to give me
advice like get off the stage and you're
bombing can we see Jeff Dunham please is
he coming down and and then this woman
in the back who was clearly exasperated
by how lost I was and she just went girl
silence is the only language men
understand and it was like blew my mind
the idea to not constantly engage with
someone that I'm gonna fight with or not
scream at them or get in some kind of
coral or altercation
so silence is the only language men
understand
I just trans like that is just like you
don't always have to try to communicate
with someone if they're not
understanding what you're saying there's
really no point but what I didn't learn
about that is if you're gonna be silent
with a guy which means you just need to
take your tongue girl take your time
collect your thoughts if you're in an
emotional place there's no point in
talking because number one you're gonna
mean your trauma response they're gonna
be in there trauma response they're not
gonna be hearing what you're saying
they're just gonna you know when you're
gonna fight and it becomes about how
you're fighting well you're rolling your
eyes of me like what are we even
fighting about like I don't even know
what we're fighting about anymore right
you always do that you always do that
thing where you walk away when I'm
talking it's like well okay now we're
just fighting about fighting and it just
turns into a big old fucking rat king
shit show but if you're gonna be silent
when you're emotional which I highly
highly encourage that you just take a
couple days and collect yourself because
feelings are not facts let the feelings
dissipate and then come back and be
super rational and but if you're gonna
be silent in a relationship if you're
gonna take a couple days and not respond
the person you have to let them know
because what I recently pieces together
was that you know everyone always talks
about how women watch romantic comedies
and they're full of
stereotypes and they created all these
unrealistic expectations and conditioned
us to like be obsessed with men and
marriage men watched these movies - you
made them go we watched romantic
comedies but so did men and while we
learned that all that matters is
marriage and all that matters is you
know getting a man to love you and that
we should all get makeovers and stuff
that men learned that when you do
something bad
in order to apologize do a grandiose
gesture go find her at the airport stop
her from getting on her flight if you
cheated on her go to her work and
confront her about it during the work
day at the magazine she wears Esther's
wedding we're in there it's like there
was like a guy would screw up and the
scene between the other guys well dude
you just gotta go apologize just go get
her at the airport or you know just go
go find her at work and tell her how you
feel because like she's at work she's a
woman but like what job could she
possibly have that's important surgery
scene where like the woman who's been
wronged is like giving a presentation
right it's always like a glass office
and she's like giving a big presentation
in like Vince Vaughn or whoever runs up
and it's like Bing Bing they make like
on the window and she's like giving a
presentation to like a bunch of
businessmen and she's like hold on guys
I got to step outside for a second and
goes and likes talks to the schlub that
she did on it and like forgives him all
the men like she's so emotional you know
show you that part I mean the men used
to like show up at airports in movies
just I don't know what the the exchange
policy for flights was back then was
there ever a point where there wasn't a
cancellation fee that's all anything
about they always just talked the the
ticket attendant into letting them go I
have two human-to-human don't you have
to get a ticket to go through TSA like
now would be a version where he's like
running with his shoes off he can't have
any liquids but like you so if you're
gonna go silent make sure you tell the
guy you're gonna go sign that or else
he'll just show up at your house because
this generation of man just learned if
you don't hear from her go to our house
you know get a boom
box and just stand in front of her door
until she answers you're gonna disappear
do it in style throw in a smoke bomb
Houdini but I did find that like a
couple times when I first tried to
enforce that boundary for myself I'd be
like okay I'm just not gonna text this
guy back I'm gonna calm down and I'm
gonna respond when I'm less emotional
and then I would just like onstage and
they'd be like I need to talk to you and
I be like I'm performing can we talk
after dude into the mic let everyone
hear okay I feel like we covered that
yeah I said I was gonna be quick but I'm
a liar okay I don't know where we're
getting to one of your all-time favorite
products since May do not put the mic
over to your nose to cut your hair why
not I'm shaving my nose hairs I do this
all the time what I can hear it telling
those little hairs yeah you can hear
them look does this is manscaped sent me
the nose hair trimmer and you put it
right inside your nose listen it's
cutting nose hairs inside my nose can
you believe that's what it does yes it's
incredible
I didn't know what these existed I mean
I love mine time axing my nose all this
time and it's so painful I did this to
my lover and it was very intimate
it was manscaped is dedicated to helping
you level up your full body grooming
game and they have forever changed the
grooming game with their perfect package
3.0 the perfect package 3.0 kit comes
with the essential lawnmower 3.0 which I
shaved my head with oh so why is it a
good thing to shave with because you can
make it have settings it is what I had
and yeah I use a 12 guard and I just
shaved all my hair over huh it was super
simple and if we could get the raw my
hair on my head then I also don't know
if this is in the ad but manscape sent
us this really beautiful package it's
like a it's like a very sleek black
package and you open it and look it has
all your
nail products in it the guy that I am
sleeping with I guess that's what he is
now took this and I had asked for him to
bring it back so that I could talk about
it in the ad look how sleek it is if
your lover is stealing from you
and he's still alone over there this
game's products are so great the people
you sleep with will pilfer them in the
night we have to watch him okay I have
lots of very nice things in this house
and this is what he chose to steal
there's tweezers there's little mini
scissors for your eyebrows which a lot
of guys don't know to do that the guy
that I'm dating also the other day said
oh that's who you remind me of and I
went who and he went Fran Drescher sorry
cause that's why he's been downgraded
from Glover to guy I'm sleeping with I
just figured it out and then a nail file
that is also to clean out too under your
nails look how sleek this is he's not
hot if I saw this in a guy as a bathroom
I would just be like let's put a ring on
that look how hot this is it's like
you're James Bond so it looks like a
James Bond gadget yeah I first I thought
it's so nice and I thought with a wallet
took a very cool hot futuristic sexy
wallet I'm so into it
it's where the modern man for sure
anyway can you can you can you read the
rest of this or do I have to do it I've
been reading it manscape has something
called the perfect package 3.0 it's a
kit that comes with the essential
lawnmower 3.0 isn't that what you use a
cordless body trimmer yes you use that
on your hair
let's when I shave my hair it looks
incredible look so even yeah I used the
12 guard it was super simple you're not
bleeding or anything I was worried that
it wouldn't get through there but it
sure did this is the best trimmer on the
market for those of you who need a chest
shave this is a third-generation trimmer
which features skin safe technology to
reduce manscaping accidents you know I
didn't think of that I mean you guys
could really cause some major damage if
you're not using manscaped products yeah
you can't just use some random razor you
get at the store you could you know give
yourself an accidental nipple piercing
and not even know it
you'll be the v-j down there also make
sure to use the crop cleanser to keep
your hair skin and healthy I don't know
white guys refuse to use shampoo
conditioner and soap but just buy this
please so that you don't smell like
scallops all the time inside the perfect
package you're gonna get the manscaped
crop preserver an anti chafing ball
deodorant cuz otherwise if I see random
red things on your balls I'm gonna think
it's herpes and it's not attractive so
get that product the crop Reviver which
is a testicle toner that's designed to
give you a little pep in your step
honestly I feel like whoever invented
manscape saw my first special cuz all I
did was complain about how ugly balls
were and here it is finally 15 years
later you guys listened there is a way
to tone your balls anti-age them Lube em
up put some effort in they look like
elephant ears come on let's uh let's uh
polish them the way you would have a
saddle saddle get 20% off and free
shipping with the code whitney 20 at
manscaped comm that's 20% off with Free
Shipping at manscaped comm use the code
Whitney
20 trim your chesticles with the beste
khals I believe that I should be
bilingual it's embarrassing it's really
embarrassing you know one language
it's pathetic it's arrogant frankly my
personality is not good enough to just
be one lingual all right one 11 more
languages I know so do I but we've been
talking about this because babble is
this company that we work with and I
started to take learning a new language
we'll get to that
I just want to brush up on the French
that I used to know yeah I want to learn
how to say I'm fine and every language
babble is proven to get you speaking a
language within weeks we've been in
quarantine for four months I could have
learned four languages by now I'm gonna
start with English okay babble designs
their courses with real-world
conversation in mind letting
learn everyday practical conversations
you'll actually use which is so genius
because sometimes when people try to
learn a language you're just memorizing
words but that's not how people actually
speak you come out of it being like I
can say scarf salad I can say you know
really useless things but I can't have
an actual conversation so what this does
is these like daily lessons that are 10
to 15 minutes and they start by teaching
you words and phrases and slowly and
gradually get more complex so you'll be
practicing short conversations because
the way my brain works I can't do
something for more than half an hour I
just get distracted I get bored my brain
gets tired this is genius because it's
10 to 15 minutes sort of at a time
the lessons are thoughtfully created by
over a hundred language experts their
teaching method has been scientifically
proven to be effective across multiple
studies they even have a speech
recognition technology system that helps
improve your pronunciation and accent
which is amazing that's wild
with babble you can choose from 14
different languages including Spanish
French Italian and German and Babel is
available in an app or online so your
progress will be synced across all
devices I mean everyone's got 15 minutes
a day everyone can find 15 minutes a day
that you're freaking scrolling social
media or you're just like reading a
gossip website in the bathroom in the
bath walking the dog this is like you
could be knocking out learning a
language yeah you could come out of this
smarter than you went into it yeah I
really want to get my French back so I'm
gonna keep doing the French one yeah I'd
like to learn Italians I can argue with
the rest of my family that's smart
that's very smart
right now when you purchase a three
month subscription I was let me try to
do it in French oh go for it in medium
all offensive what was month again month
is god I yeah okay go to babble I need
babble more than anyone what so month I
know that's day
what's week alright don't matter
bable hey give what's give crap our
listeners twat
months
did you know pool Li Li Libre what's
free liberty with promo code good free
ball for fook that's that that is the
name of our podcasts in French ball pour
vous
okay that was actually really impressive
I'm gonna get I'm gonna translate it but
good for you is BOM pour vous
what are they get okay I'm good I'm
gonna start doing babble in French I
don't know it I wanted to go to Italian
but I clearly need to brush up on my
French right now when you purchase a
three month subscription babble will
give our listeners wha
that's three additional months for free
with promo code good for you that's
three o'clock additional months free if
you go to babble calm and use promo code
good for you on your three month
subscription that's babble ba BB al comm
promo code ball pool good for you is
there ever a reason you should text your
ex oh noes
are there ever a reason to rifle through
your trash reserved reason give yourself
bangs no you're sad there ever a reason
to pick up roadkill off the freeway
stick your hand in a toaster put it on
the grill sir every reason to go back to
your old apartment building you have to
lived out in a couple years and just
drive around for the love of the game
see I have an interesting opinion on
this because I think it's okay to text
your eggs exclusively through venmo
because you can't delete the comments so
you can write whatever you want and your
in your request
they can't delete it so you could be
like I know you were talking to Jessica
and you bring my mom's birthday so no
one can you know the person can't delete
and it's public and to block their
account or pay that fee I actually as I
get older realize you should stay in
touch with exes
if they are useful in some way yeah yeah
right Liverpool say have a pool why not
why burn the bridge right why not stay
in contact you one punch away from a
free brewery they have one of those if
they have one of those trampolines with
the big pads on the outside and fun okay
I have an ex who is who I in my head I
always want to be like bitter with and
like punished but he's an
anesthesiologist and it's very nice to
every now and then be like hey can I mix
these two pills he's like you can thank
you sure can you like take to wash them
down with whiskey how about that it
saves me like a couple hundred dollars a
year to just like hey is this a good
dosage to take with this or like I'll
ask him for like medical advice every
now and then like someone who can ever
sleep he's a good friend I do feel like
keeping things civil with an ex who was
useful is uh is smart cuz I don't like
having wasted time like it makes me feel
like okay that whole year of my life
wasn't a complete waste you know I like
staying friends with exes you know I
have like four exes that live in my
house currently yeah thanks true and
whenever I'm hanging out with a guy I
sometimes secretly I'm like I can't wait
till like where access fee friends I
can't wait talking ask you to do stuff I
can't wait til I could ask you to do
chores without like owing you alright
what's nice should I even try to talk to
my crush during everything going on in
the world you did that was such a weird
inflection that I didn't understand I
don't know it's okay should I even try
to talk to my crush drawing everything
going on in the world should I even try
to talk to my crush with every with
everything that's going on because
there's a lot going on in the world you
understood at that time I know you did I
think now is the best time to talk to
anyone yeah I agree I cuz I believe the
hardest thing about getting into a
relationship is learning what the person
is like in a time of crisis like that's
basically what your way
right like when you start dating someone
you're like oh okay anyone can be fun
when things are going well anyone can be
nice when things are going well like you
know who are you when someone gets sick
who are you when there's chaos who are
you when there's death like that you
really want to see how someone operates
in a time of chaos and so now it's the
perfect time to find that out very early
they could be they might be the optimist
they might be the panic er they'd be the
world yeah you're really finding out who
people are right now like I have friends
that are completely like like showing
sides of themselves that I had never
seen before and I'm like oh god if I was
dating you I would not want to find this
out three years then put the mask back
on
yeah but um but you had a good point
about this about how dating like zoom
dating or FaceTime dating is a great way
to actually get one-on-one there's no
one to facilitate your date for you yeah
normally on dates you go and there's you
go to a comedy show the comedian
facilitates the day you go to a
restaurant the restaurant facilities
there's always something you can enjoy
or talk about or hate together yeah yeah
it's like if you go to a movie and you
had a great date that just means the
movie was good you're like we did we
love this movie yeah it's gonna talk
about but the movie did all the work
yeah and I like you can go out with
people ten times and have no idea who
they are like your constant going to
like a show or going access keywords
going on dates and throwing axes like
how could that not be at least a little
energy if you hated that date you could
be like wait took me to throw max I was
like hey let's go throw axes I would not
I've seen that on Instagram I didn't
realize people like when on date yeah I
mean even if you go to a restaurant you
guys hate it then you're just bonding
over how you hated the later yeah it's
so true but now the pressure is all on
your personality you tell a joke is that
a good answer no I mean yeah yes it is
it's never a good time today anyone so
just fucking do it but it leaves a shit
at least now you need your damn pajamas
with your own life yeah exactly exactly
you get to choose your lighting you do
to mute people yeah I just don't I don't
think there's ever a good or bad
to date anyone it just it is what it is
was that profound the next question is
and this is also a fight we got in
should I look through my partner's phone
or not you want to roleplay this one
okay I'm gonna say my opinion first and
then Benton and I will roleplay this has
been a source of tension in my household
for the past week with Benton I'm first
gonna say how what I believe I believe
no one should ever go through anyone's
phone I believe at 37 I didn't believe
this at 25 at 37 I believe that if you
have the instinct to go through your
partner's phone it's over you should
just leave if you think you should do
that if you want to do that
that is because you will find what
you're looking for you're just looking
for proof of what you already know or
already believe and I've never heard
someone be like I went through a
hunter's phone because I thought he was
cheating and I found pictures of me
perfect engagement ring I wanted like
it's the story's never gone that way
like even if the phone is full of benign
stuff you're gonna find a way to twist
it into the proof that you're already
looking for to justify and what I'll say
is everyone's got shit in their phone
that is gonna hurt you like like if
we're together right now you can go
through my phone and find something
that's gonna hurt you but it's none of
your business like these are private
conversations like I was thinking about
this because I was trying to figure out
a way to win this fight with you today
and like guys you have private
conversations when the girlfriends not
around girls have private conversation
when their guys aren't around those are
in my phone now but you're not allowed
to hear those properly the only reason a
relationship works is because I'm
allowed to complain about you with my
girlfriends it's never for you to see
uh-huh so I'm not really sure how I feel
about it but I do know I have an opinion
Bentham believes I just think what are
you you have if you have nothing to hide
you have nothing to hide but if you
think I have something to hide why are
you with me who said I thought that why
are you bright see okay okay let's do
the roleplay okay let's do the robot so
I am me and you okay that's a good start
is my phone here does the phone have a
password it doesn't matter why
okay so here's my okay I'm just doing
what I'm doing dude to do drink my
coffee see your phone what can I see
your phone for what I just might go
through it what I just wanna go through
your phone why I just want to you might
add you may have some pictures that I
want to send myself or her nose well
what are they I'll send him yesterday
why can't I see your phone well what do
you need out of them I just want to see
your phone why can't I
well the only reason I feel worried
about it is that you're coming up with
me with such a grow energy I feel like
you're looking oh I thought it's pretty
nice I'm sorry can I please see your
phone for what I told you I just want to
go through it but what which apps your
text messages your do you wanna go
through my text you can't go through my
text - because those are private
conversations yeah but I mean we're
sharing a life together so should I be
able to see your your messages no
because I talked to my friends sometimes
about you
and I you shouldn't see that okay well
are you saying negative things maybe I
don't know I don't really find out let
me see your phone no but I there's this
isn't my personal so you're hiding
something aren't we all I know you think
that what a relationship is he my phone
okay do you want to see it I'll put up
the TV well err planet what are you
gonna do I'm gonna go through all your
stuff but we're broken up now
now we're branching out toys I didn't
wanna break up I just want to see your
phone no but no but no healthy
relationship wants personal relation
wants that feels like you just have
something to hide you want to switch it
I hate what the argument of well I'll
let you see mine it's like okay well I
don't want to see you are a monster but
what are you looking for here let's
switch it I'll play your case but are
you just trying to see my phone this is
it I would never do that I can't get a
better handle because when I was in my
20s I secretly went through guys phones
and it always ended in the fucking
disaster and I should have just left
when I had the instinct to do it because
I already knew everything I needed to
know based on I don't show you how to
handle that okay uh can I see your phone
you sure can
but I called you a bitch a couple times
in it I did I've done a couple methods
in my friends I called you a bitch why
you're being a bitch
you can look there's a time and a date
on there you'll know when how is this
healthy for anyone you ask that's the
truth but I alright maybe I'm wrong
there are some pictures of girls a
screenshot on Instagram what yeah just
so you know ill what did you want to see
on there
I didn't you made me roleplay this part
I I never want to see a guy's picture
I think people shouldn't be shitty I
even had this problem here been tonight
in fights because I'm sure they listen
to this podcast but all of his
girlfriends sound like the craziest
people I've ever heard of he's like well
I have a girlfriend who in the middle of
the night will jerry-rigged the phone
charger with dental floss and pull of a
crazy pulls her boyfriend's phone out
from under the mattress and goes through
it every night that's crazy I like a
girl who will fight you that's crazy
behavior I also think there was another
um I think this is a voicemail question
but I feel like we should just address
it now you know like there's also the
deal is with phones a phone is a
different thing now than it was back
when I was insecure in relationships is
she had a dial in a circle kiss her
because it was two pieces
it was just Morse code someone asked
what does it mean when my girlfriend
brings her phone to the bathroom like
that was a voicemail means she's
shitting that's what it means what do
you want to do stare at the wall think
about you what the fuck does that even
mean yeah I mean what the hell no but
when I cheated in my 20s I used to bring
my phone to the bathroom like I bring it
with me wherever I went because I didn't
want the person that I was cheating with
to text or call or something like that
but now if someone it's weird it's like
I would have had a different answer 7 5
7 years ago that I would now now it's
like texting and phone calls is like the
fifth thing I do on my phone it's like
back when a phone was just for phone
calls and texts I would say if someone
brings it with them wherever they go and
like to the bathroom and it's really
sketchy about it but now it's like I'm
doing nine other playing candy crush
leave her alone yeah I'm build
my brand okay every time I go to the
bathroom that's like two more you know
posts I could have made watching Netflix
um sponsored content over here like so I
think that I would say that for older
generations it's sketchier but for
younger people whatever but that's
another reason to go back why going
through someone's phone I think is like
even more not okay now because it's got
all my shit yeah totally it's not just
for texts I don't think you should go to
call so but I think that if you're that
defensive about it then you are doing
something wrong why else would you be
defense I half agree but I also think
that like I'm being defensive because
you're accusing me if I under radical
honesty hmm and erratic I know that's a
Will and Jada did and okay so I think we
have a couple voicemails yep oh you only
have one more question if you want to do
it okay what this is the biggest fight
me and my partner get in please help us
do knives go in the dishwasher three
weeks ago I would have told you they do
that's because you were using plastic
butter knives but I recently bought a
nice pair of knives because Benton's
forcing me to be a cooking influencer
and I bought these nice knives on Amazon
and I put them in the dishwasher and the
handle went from like a beautiful wood
to like a crusty discussing rust it
ruined the metal it'll say yeah you
cannot put knives in a dishwasher
they're not nice things and you cannot
put jeans in the washing machine that we
are the source of all important
information on this podcast we're
putting on headphones for voicemails
okay people have started in the comments
to do a drinking games when you touch
your glasses what do you mean because
you touch them so much so like we're
gonna take shots are touching touches
them in somebody about time day it
waitwhat glasses these you when you have
glasses on you take them on and off and
on and off and you movement to come on
olá you know people have started like
doing games out of it that's so funny I
also do this word up Whitney and Benton
this is Heather proud of Florida I have
some nervous Nellie rude as hell
coworkers that doesn't matter how nice
or sweet or professional I am they're
still a bunch of a-holes so I'm just
curious in this time of pandemic what
sort of advice or different type of
greeting or note could I possibly give
of encouragement or just a little hey
don't be an a-hole without going over
the line
peace are you opening with word up yeah
when you see your co-workers and are you
closing your greetings with boots this
is for sure the person the office who
knows everyone's birthday who decorates
the cubicle for every event we love her
she's the girl that wears like the the
Christmas ornament earrings yeah she
does a Halloween wasn't like light up
and give everyone's seizures I would
like to know what kind of co-workers you
have that are both nervous Nellie's and
rude as hell
that's a hard place we're in a pandemic
I think you have to keep your bar very
low for people's behavior right now I
think we all have to be radically
forgiving and not expect anything and I
also don't think you need to be nice to
people that are owed to you they don't
deserve it
so just stop talking to them please
don't take advice about a professional
attitude from Benton Wray
okay professional Benton comes in every
morning and does not even say hello to
me I have to be like hi you're busy good
morning and you're like hi who wants the
person come back hello wait nice hope
your day is going good I'm like here's
your coffee are we ready to go what I I
literally have to like make you say hi
to me I don't want to bother you
I'll go because I'm professional I'll go
good morning and ho go hi like as if I'm
annoying you as it is do not take
professional demeanor advice from Benton
mini office job but uh yeah I would just
say stop expecting anything from anyone
right now
you know don't expect people to be in
good moods everyone's a big grumpy mess
right now you seem really great so just
you know golf that yeah just wear a mask
so that you can talk to anyone that's a
night the best part about wearing a mask
is you can mom
obscenities about people under your
breath and they won't hear you you keep
you a new girl do you piece
word up she was like a-holes sir meaning
she's so Q those mean heads we're up me
nuts yeah there's nothing you can do
because I find like he just leaves the
room I just yeah I just think we have to
expect nothing from anyone right now
everybody's like a grumpy mess like I
have this one the Amazon delivery guy
was like legitimately my friend we talk
about dogs and the other day I made the
mistake of trying to befriend another
one and he literally I was like hey Lee
I opened the gate and he just like threw
the package yeah he that works yeah okay
you know what I get it I get it
fair fair nothing quit orange I know I
literally had like a jump to the side I
was like Jesus um okay here's our next
one okay
what's up Whitney this is vampire no I
mean my artificial intelligence
programmer for stock trading just wanted
to call senior Facebook page and just
think that you're a wonderful person
hilarious and that uh these six robots
just remember that if a man hooks up
with a sex robot he's gay it's not a
woman I don't care how much it looks
like a woman how much it feels like a
woman he's gay there's no substitute on
this earth for a real woman alright have
a good day so just remember when robots
come out and they start taking off the
work taking over the world just a bunch
of gay guys hanging out feels like a man
who's put a lot of rules on what's gay
and what's not he's living in some some
hard boundaries for some reason okay
serious such a queer
I uh I disagree sir
his name is vampire vampire sorry
vampire I I disagree with you uh I think
the straightest shit you can do is fuck
a doll that looks like a woman I think I
don't think a gay guys like you know oh
this doll looks like a woman has
basically a butthole like are you just
saying that my sex robot looks like a
butthole like I don't understand when he
started set you know I think it's the
straightest shit you can do is just fuck
anything with a hole yeah it's a hard
disagree vampire I thought was put into
bed I can't imagine a man that calls
himself vampire would ever be wrong
about anything
he's an artificial intelligence
programmer for stock trading I don't
know what that means
sounds like a lie doesn't it it sounds
like a lie that's too convoluted to
refute that's the one you can get away
with for a long time because it's one of
those is one of those lies that makes
you think you're stupid
yeah being a vampire yeah thank you for
your input
he was also warning so Whitney when that
happened don't you worry it's just some
gay guys don't you be nervous Whitney
straight guys would never be attracted
to something that looks like you I think
that's kind of what he's saying
alright cool legs okay oh there we go
here's the next one
oh fuck you can't do this
I was gonna invite you but I can't do it
that was such a cute little voice
message entry okay I'm gonna do it
hey not it's like a roast kind of okay
just oh shit
hey not that you're funnier when you
were younger but if you look younger
you'd be funnier
it's not even funny and not euro thing
I'm sorry have a good night Oh which one
of your friends was this it's funny
because I'm a roast joke that's not
funny or mean enough is just hurtful
yeah she could just read the comments
and she said what was in their joke that
doesn't hit is just a fact I you know
what I I was really looking forward to
that being like Oh super mean joke but I
don't think it was that mean no I like
if you guys want to do roast jokes to me
go for it I'm all out of tears nothing
hurts my feelings anymore I've gone numb
I welcome them just don't come for my
robot she's got she is sensitive we just
put tear ducts in her that was cute yeah
I like that it was a kiss scared she got
started off with oh fuck I can't do all
comedies so that's great all right
here's our next one hey Whitney I was
wondering what is a good way for male
fans of like female comedians other
female performers to be supportive and
when we get interactions every now and
like I get a message back on Twitter or
something like that or response to a DM
I want I'm gonna respond I respond
naturally I sometimes might not get a
response and I understand a lot of it's
part of the fact that they get a million
messages a time but I always there's
that anxiety that I'm worried like oh
did I come off as a creep or as my
messaging coming off weird and creepy
fans so I can be a little I can be
enthusiastic and excited and I want his
people to be my friends inside my head
but yeah I'm just in through the aspect
and I want to make sure to hear your
advice on what's a good way to be a
respectful and supportive fan without
coming off like a creep any advice you
get will be
helpful Thanks I'm literally tearing I'm
crying I mean yeah it's very sleep that
just made me cry oh god that really did
just make me much no because I can't
explain pausing fulfilling I'm sorry
we're holding for emotion I'm truly oh
can we go back four minutes ago when
she's like I have no tears grossed me
I've never cried in my lives I can't
believe that was one Illit answer it so
that was just I think that there's it so
sad that when a guy's just like hey how
can I be respectful it's just like it's
so touching my it's like the bar is so
low I just want to be respectful to a
woman it's just it is so moving I just
really appreciated that it was very nice
Oh God I was so chipper about it too
yeah I know he was just like I want to
do the right thing and I don't want to
when just when he said I feel like you
guys are my friends in my head it just
really very touching I'm sorry can you
talk sure
well now wiping my eyes with your meal
with my Mientus yes also great as a
kerchief when you unexpectedly start
sobbing because a man was nice yes
so basically I need this questions
pretty simple to answer you just want to
treat them the way you would treat a
male comedian like you know buy tickets
to their shows share their clips when
they post them don't talk about their
bodies uh-huh don't give them advice
after the show don't welcome be like or
don't leave advice in a comment because
you don't know being a fan of something
does not mean you know about it yeah I
don't want to be too shitty to this guy
what's on him I know but I'm just saying
cuz it was just so sweet and that was so
unexpectedly
moving to me as someone who I feel like
my entire career guys come up to me
after shows and they're like yay I
didn't even you're so funny I didn't
even think you are a woman or like just
like you know all them female comedians
wannabe comics just like yeah totally
like my favor I normally don't think
women are funny no you're funny and you
know I can't believe that I want to fuck
you but you're also funny like I mean
just the shit I've heard for so long
it's just for a guy for anyone to just
be like hey I'm just trying to be a fan
without making you feel weird and I
don't want to accidentally make you feel
weird like just the cut this
consciousness of this person just is so
cool to me
I begin to he's probably not making
people feel weird because he is so
Casey's conscious daddy says I mean the
thing you don't have welcome be like you
know you're my favorite female comedian
is not a compliment yeah no one would
ever be like you're my favorite female
your doctor you're just pitting women
against each other in that that's right
well cuz the other thing is people do is
they'll come up to you and just start
trashing other female comments yeah
which most are my friends they just come
be like you know who sucks you know like
that she's my friend and I think she's
great light or whatever or you don't
have to say you're so funny and
beautiful oh yeah no I but I think I
think for that what I will say is just
any emoji except the squirt emoji the
little droplets the drooling face the
drooling face the wink I don't think you
I think people don't share how creepy
the winged face comes off whether they
intend it or not if you're like you're
so funny wink then I'm like wait some
doesn't a winky face and the gate the
thing you just said like just JK isn't
Winky basically equivalent to JK at this
point we don't do the wink it's like
flirting
you're the first two rows of smiley
emoji stick to that the first two rows
downward that's all you need no eggplant
no devil don't send the little devil
that always means like I'm gonna dumb on
the prowl on the devil I'm gonna get you
yeah totally horny I think it really
gets weird in the emojis like that's
where it gets tricky otherwise you know
and then I would also not assume the
right shrimp is okay you can send that
one what does that mean you know but
it's funny it looks like a little
curled-up dick I don't know I would
probably
Brio but yeah I would say look here's
what'll say it's very hard to creep out
a female comic it actually kind of is
because they're living in terror all the
time so you're probably doing fine as
long as you're not using the squirt the
devil the eggplant the Winky yeah and
neither this advice is good advice to
give to any yeah I Nora tea comedian if
you're black if they're gay if they're
trained yes don't they're just a
comedian they're not your novelty talk
yes yes yes yes but I do think it's good
to think like Oh cuz things that you put
online or in comments or text don't
always construe like tone yeah you know
sometimes people are just gonna play
around with you they say because you're
a comedian and you're brash and you do
other things then I can do that in the
comment and it translates the same yeah
I know it doesn't it doesn't so just
keep it simple
yeah like our stuff buy tickets super
easy but sure the clone I love this man
where's he from
does it say where he was from no I can
guess or his name I then call him back
and just saying thank you the irony is
the best way to get a female comic to
fall in love with you is to do what he
just did to be respected whatever he
just did that is the game you should
throw female comics because I am like
madly in love with that guy now that was
a very sweet oh god that was so shocking
least that was so surprisingly emotional
San Antonio
my man Forbes did he say his name or
anything no I'm in love with him if you
are the person who left that voicemail
please find us you're gonna make him
creepy wait so you don't want to fuck me
is that what you're saying you don't
think I'm odd now you're the probe yeah
wait you don't want to creep me out you
know you don't think I'm sexy I'm a
woman damn man you just see me as a
comedian oh damn it equality is very
confusing now I feel rejected and ugly
oh that was fun
that really was I feel like I feel like
a lot of I feel like a lot of old stuff
came up I can't believe was rafter you
just said you don't cry I'm faster than
you could we could get to the next
message that was what that was wild
that was wild I feel like I worked
through a lot of old invisible wounds
and a lot of old pain just came up and
you know I'm I'm not I'm not gonna
suppress tears anymore I'm gonna just
let him flow you know
this roast will work out great roast me
okay we've got a rep up because this is
going way too long we are gonna I
believe have a guest next week I was on
Kimmel this week if you guys want to
re-watch that it was on ABC any other
announcements you want to make a merch
there the that's not six feet masks are
sold out they're coming back though but
you guys love them yeah but all the
other merch is still out there you can
grab them if you want it we have we're
working on new merch we're gonna do
merch that says bap bap bap yeah we're
working on lots of merge we're doing
wild merch why are you giving it all the
way it's a social shit sorry we are
working on merged plural lots of fun
merch lots of things that you may not
even know expected o rights plot twists
we can't you know people on the internet
love to go we have a big project can't
talk about it right now
yeah I'm not secretive I'm like I'll
tell you guys you're the ones bank I'm
excited we're having a ballad to talk
about the product yeah because you're
building up tension there's a we have a
product coming out for a beauty products
okay but I'm not saying but you can't
say what but don't you guys want to know
now you're gonna be on the lookout what
is this fucking scavenger hunt we just
tell them because what doesn't build
tension or exciting marketing is not my
strong suit just like comedy you're
loading tension you're putting tension
marketing is not where I shine okay and
elephants don't write elephants I can
subscribe Oh YouTube oh that's right
like subscribe all the the logistics
three tooth nope
eight one eight two three nine seven
five to seven text me guest ideas I've
actually been taking a lot of y'all's
guests ideas if you want to leave a
voice now it's eight one eight five
three eight nine nine four zero and we
might play it and I dare you to try to
make me cry up all it really takes is a
sincere compliment at this point needed
totally emotionally unravel anything
else I don't think so okay I think
that's pretty much yeah we're with that
was a great you're put what are you
doing I'm putting lipstick on for who
myself
there you go see you learn see there we
were just testing I just want to think
how you would answer that no we're about
to record some ads as well so it's not
for you
you don't you learn nothing I want to
make sure that the better help people
think I'm pretty
that is good mental health okay bye guys
thank you